que esta crisis fuera una oportunidad para Grecia, para Europa,
para el mundo, para hacer las transformaciones democráticas radicales
en nuestras instituciones.
En cambio, tuve una lección de humildad.
En Bruselas, cuando intentamos desesperadamente una y otra vez
encontrar soluciones comunes,
me di cuenta de que ninguno, ninguno de nosotros,
nunca había tratado con una crisis similar.
Pero peor aún, estábamos atrapados en nuestra ignorancia colectiva.
Fuimos guiados por nuestros miedos.
Y nuestros temores nos condujeron a una fe ciega
en la ortodoxia de la austeridad.
En lugar de acercarse al común
o la a sabiduría colectiva de nuestras sociedades,
invirtiendo en ella para encontrar soluciones más creativas,
nos devolvimos a la postura política.
Y entonces nos sorprendimos cuando cada
nueva medida ad hoc no ponía fin a la crisis,
y por supuesto esto hace muy fácil
buscar a un chivo expiatorio
por nuestro fracaso colectivo europeo,
y por supuesto ese fue Grecia.
Los griegos derrochadores, perezosos, bebedores de ouzo, bailarines de Zorba,
ellos son el problema. ¡Castiguémoslos!
Bueno, un estereotipo infundado pero conveniente
lo que a veces dolió aún más que la austeridad misma.
Pero déjeme advertirles, no se trata solo de Grecia.
Este podría ser el patrón
que los líderes seguimos una y otra vez
cuando nos ocupamos de estos problemas complejos, transnacionales,
sea el cambio climático, la migración,
o el sistema financiero.
Es decir, abandonar nuestro poder colectivo
de imaginar nuestro potencial,
caer víctimas de nuestros miedos, nuestros estereotipos, nuestros dogmas,
sacando a nuestros ciudadanos fuera del proceso,
en vez de construir el proceso alrededor de nuestros ciudadanos.
Y hacerlo, solo probará la fe
de nuestros ciudadanos, de nuestros pueblos, aún más,
en el proceso democrático.
No es de extrañar que muchos líderes políticos,
y no me excluyo,
hayan perdido la confianza de sus pueblos.
Cuando la policía antidisturbios tiene que proteger los parlamentos,
una escena que es cada vez más común en el mundo,
entonces hay algo profundamente equivocado en nuestras democracias.
Por eso hice un llamado a un referéndum para que el pueblo griego
se apropiara y decidiera los términos del paquete de rescate.
Mis colegas europeos, algunos de ellos, al menos,
dijeron: "No puede hacer eso.
Habrá caos en los mercados otra vez".
Yo dije, "Lo necesitamos, antes que restablecer la confianza de los mercados,
tenemos que restablecer la seguridad y la confianza entre nuestros pueblos".
Desde que abandoné el cargo, he tenido tiempo para reflexionar.
Hemos capeado el temporal, en Grecia y en Europa,
pero seguimos siendo desafiados.
Si la política es el poder de imaginar y utilizar nuestro potencial,
bien, entonces, el 60 % de desempleo juvenil en Grecia,
y en otros países, es sin duda una falta de imaginación
si no una falta de compasión.
Hasta ahora, hemos lanzado economía al problema,
realmente sobre todo austeridad,
y sin duda podríamos haber diseñado alternativas,
una estrategia diferente, un estímulo verde para empleos verdes,
o mutualizar la deuda, eurobonos con que
apoyar a los países necesitados por las presiones del mercado,
estas habrían sido alternativas más viables.
Sin embargo he llegado a creer que el problema no es tanto
económico como uno de la democracia.
Así que intentemos algo más.
Vamos a ver cómo podemos traer gente hacia el proceso.
Vamos a lanzar democracia al problema.
Una vez más, los antiguos griegos, con todos sus defectos,
creían en la sabiduría de la multitud
en sus mejores momentos. Confiamos en la gente.
La democracia no podría funcionar sin los ciudadanos
deliberando, debatiendo, asumiendo responsabilidades públicas
de asuntos públicos.
Los ciudadanos promedio a menudo fueron elegidos como jurados
para decidir sobre asuntos críticos del momento.
Ciencia, investigación, teatro, filosofía,
juegos de la mente y el cuerpo,
eran ejercicios diarios.
Realmente fueron una educación para la participación,
el potencial para crecer, el potencial de nuestros ciudadanos.
Y los que rechazaban la política, pues eran idiotas.
Verán, en la antigua Grecia, en la antigua Atenas,
ese término se originó allí.
"Idiota" proviene de la raíz "idio", uno mismo.
Una persona que es egocéntrica, aislada, excluida,
alguien que no participa o incluso no examina asuntos públicos.
Y la participación tuvo lugar en la ágora, la ágora tiene dos significados,
un mercado y un lugar donde se produjo la deliberación política.
Ven, mercados y política eran entonces uno, unificado,
accesible, transparente, porque dieron el poder al pueblo.
Sirven al 'demos' [pueblo], democracia.
Sobre el gobierno, por encima de los mercados
estaba la regla directa del pueblo.
Hoy hemos globalizado los mercados
pero no hemos globalizado nuestras instituciones democráticas.
Así que nuestros políticos se limitan a la política local,
mientras los ciudadanos, aunque ven un gran potencial,
son presa de fuerzas ajenas a su voluntad.
Así que, ¿cómo reunificamos las dos mitades de la ágora?
¿Cómo democratizamos la globalización?
Y no estoy hablando de las reformas necesarias
de las Naciones Unidas o el G-20.
Estoy hablando, de cómo aseguramos el espacio,
el pueblo, la plataforma de valores,
por los que podemos aprovechar todo su potencial.
Bueno, esto es exactamente donde creo que Europa encaja.
Europa, a pesar de sus fracasos recientes,
es el experimento de paz transfronteriza más exitoso del mundo.
Así que veamos si no puede ser un experimento
en la democracia global, un nuevo tipo de democracia.
Vamos a ver si no podemos diseñar una ágora europea,
no solo para los productos y servicios,
sino para nuestros ciudadanos, donde puedan trabajar juntos,
deliberar, aprender unos de otros,
intercambiar entre arte y culturas,
donde se puede topar con soluciones creativas.
Imaginemos que los ciudadanos europeos
realmente tienen el poder de votar directamente
por un presidente europeo,
o ser jurados ciudadanos elegidos por sorteo
que puedan deliberar sobre cuestiones críticas y polémicas,
un referéndum pan-europeo donde nuestros ciudadanos,
como los legisladores voten en futuros tratados.
Y aquí está una idea:
¿Por qué no tenemos los primeros ciudadanos verdaderamente europeos
dando a nuestros inmigrantes,
ciudadanía no griega o alemana o sueca,
sino una ciudadanía europea?
Y asegurándonos de que realmente potenciamos
los desempleados dándoles una beca para
poder estudiar en cualquier lugar de Europa.
Donde nuestra identidad común es la democracia,
dónde nuestra educación es a través de la participación,
y donde la participación genera confianza
y solidaridad en lugar de exclusión y xenofobia.
Europa de y para la gente,
una Europa, un experimento en la profundización y ampliación
democrática más allá de las fronteras.
Ahora, algunos podrían acusarme de ser ingenuo,
al poner mi fe en el poder y la sabiduría del pueblo.
Bueno, después de décadas en la política, yo también soy un pragmático.
Créanme, he sido,
soy parte del sistema político actual,
y sé que las cosas deben cambiar.
Debemos revivir la política como el poder de imaginar,
reimaginar y rediseñar un mundo mejor.
Pero también sé que esta disruptiva fuerza de cambio
no debe ser conducida por la política de hoy.
El renacimiento de la política democrática
vendrá de Uds. y me refiero a todos Uds.
Todo aquel que participa en este intercambio global de ideas,
sea aquí en esta sala
o fuera de esta sala
o en línea o localmente, donde cada uno vive,
todo aquel que se levanta ante la injusticia y la desigualdad,
todo el que se levanta ante los predicadores del
racismo en lugar de la empatía,
del dogma en lugar del pensamiento crítico,
de la tecnocracia, en lugar de la democracia,
todos los que se enfrentan al poder sin control,
sea de líderes autoritarios,
plutócratas ocultando sus activos en paraísos fiscales,
o aquellos poderosos que cabildean protegiendo a unos pocos con poder.
Es de su interés que todos nosotros seamos idiotas.
No lo seamos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Parece describir un liderazgo político
que no está preparado
y es preso de los caprichos de los mercados financieros,
y esa escena en Bruselas que Ud. describe, para mí,
como ciudadano, es terrible.
Ayúdenos a entender cómo se sentía después de la decisión.
Claramente no fue una buena decisión,
pero, ¿cómo se siente después de eso, no como primer ministro,
sino como George?
George Papandreou: Bueno, obviamente había limitaciones
que no me permitían a mí o a otros tomar
los tipos de decisiones que hubiésemos querido,
y obviamente esperaba que haber tenido el tiempo
para hacer las reformas que se habrían ocupado
del déficit, en lugar de intentar reducir el déficit
que era el síntoma del problema.
Y eso dolió. Eso dolió porque, ante todo,
lastima a la generación más joven y no solo,
muchos de ellos se están manifestando afuera,
pero creo que este es uno de nuestros problemas.
Cuando enfrentamos estas crisis, hemos mantenido el potencial,
el enorme potencial de nuestra sociedad, fuera de este proceso,
y nos estamos encerrando nosotros mismos en la política,
y creo que tenemos que cambiar esto, realmente encontrar
nuevas formas de participación mediante las grandes capacidades
que ahora existen incluso en tecnología pero no solo en tecnología,
las mentes que tenemos, y creo que podemos encontrar soluciones
que son mucho mejores, pero tenemos que estar abiertos.
BG: Parece sugerir que el camino a seguir
es más Europa, y no debe ser un discurso fácil
ahora en la mayoría de los países europeos.
Es más bien lo contrario, más fronteras cerradas
y menos cooperación y tal vez incluso separarse
de algunas de las diferentes partes de la construcción europea.
¿Cómo conciliar esto?
GP: Bien, creo que una de las peores cosas que sucedieron
durante esta crisis es que comenzamos un juego de culpa.
Y la idea fundamental de Europa es que
podemos cooperar más allá de las fronteras,
más allá de nuestros conflictos y trabajar juntos.
Y la paradoja es que, dado que tenemos este juego de culpa,
tenemos menos potencial para convencer a los ciudadanos
de que debemos trabajar juntos,
mientras que ahora es el momento en que realmente necesitamos
reunir nuestros poderes.
Ahora, más Europa para mí no es simplemente
darle más poder a Bruselas.
Es realmente darles más poder a los ciudadanos de Europa,
es decir, realmente hacer de Europa un proyecto de la gente.
Por lo que, creo, sería una forma de responder a
algunos de los temores que tenemos en nuestra sociedad.
BG: George, gracias por venir a TED.
GP: Muchas gracias. BG: Gracias. (Aplausos)